scp-682 vs scp-2337  could the heart of destroy reptile meet  its end at the dangerously booming voice  of the talkative dr spangkow as part of  a tissue test dr spanko was told 682's  flesh was a tone-deaf food critic who  needed to be convinced on what the  greatest food in existence was spanko  argued so loudly that the answer was  gummy worms that it destroyed 682's  flesh the next step was sending him in  to talk the actual 682 to death after  being told the reptile was an anti-gummy  worm extremist this seemed promising  until dr spanko confidently entered the  chamber and 682 simply boomed  at which point dr spanko turned  literally yelled the wall down and did  just that 682 must really hate gummy  worms